welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Baron hard Shema the European Union
visiting fellow at Yale University mr.
Shima is a legal adviser in the European
Commission's legal service he has
studied law in Vienna where he was born
and in Paris and at Harvard Law School
from 1995 to 2003 he was a member of the
chamber of Judge dr. Peter jhana at to
the European Court of Justice he has
taught and published extensively on
various matters of European Union law
today we talk with him about the
application of EU fundamental rights to
the Member States after Lisbon and
putting the case law of European Court
of Justice into perspective
welcome mr. Shima thank you very much
for having me okay so your research
focuses on the application of the EU
fundamental rights to the Member States
after the Treaty of Lisbon so I guess we
need to talk about what the Treaty of
Lisbon is and also the EU fundamental
rights and then what actually changed
when that happened
yes well the the Treaty of Lisbon is the
treaty which gave the foundations of the
European Union its current form those
are two basic treaties that have started
to apply at the end of 2009 and when we
talk about fundamental rights we mean
what you would normally find in some
kind of the Bill of Rights right the
freedom of expression the freedom of
religion freedom of association and
European Union fundamental rights were
not originally included in such a bill
of rights of the Union it was rather the
European Court of Justice which in its
case law developed such fundamental
rights as general principles of European
Union law and it found those general
principles on the one hand by looking at
the common constitutional traditions of
the Member State
and on the other hand by looking at
international conventions for the
protection of human rights to which the
member states where parties so what now
changed with the Lisbon treaty was that
a binding set of fundamental rights was
finally included as a proper source of
european union law that so-called
Charter of Fundamental Rights of the
European Union was thrown up already in
the year 2000 but at that time it was
not made formally binding so that is
what the lisbon treaty now changed it
put it at the same level of the treaties
and made it therefore a binding source
of european union law okay why did it
why was it not binding from the very
beginning why did it have to become
binding down the road well because
member states are actually quite afraid
I think some member states at least that
the European Union might start to look
like a state and normally a binding set
of fundamental rights a bill of rights
is something that you typically find in
a national constitution and some member
states who don't want the European Union
to turn into a state would be quite
concerned by that this is why
fundamental rights have only made their
way into European Union law slowly and
step-by-step mm-hmm okay how many member
states are there who are now adhering to
this there are today 28 member states we
started out with six member states of
the Union and then it expanded there was
a very big expansion of the European
Union in 2004 when 10 member states
joined at once and the latest exception
was Croatian as recently as 1st of July
2013 ok so now they are all operating
under these same fundamental rights to a
certain extent the problem here is that
everyone can more or less easily accept
that European Union fundamental rights
should apply to act of the European you
right the European Union is a treaty
with is a Treaty Organization if you
want but it has its own institutions
which act and adopt pieces of what we
call secondary legislation and the
legislation adopted by those
institutions certainly needs to be
checked against fundamental rights and
that is what member states are still
more or less comfortable with because
even if you are sort of skeptical of
European integration you're going to say
okay fundamental rights are going to
limit the action of the Union
institutions and we don't have to be so
worried about a potential encroachment
of the Union upon member state
competences where it gets more
problematic though is when you want to
apply those same fundamental rights to
the Member States in that case the acts
the rules of one authority let's say the
Union are going to reach into the sphere
of another Authority the Member States
and the Member States all have their own
fundamental rights of course and they
don't necessarily see why suddenly the
rights of the Union should also apply to
what they do can you draw on any
specific examples of that becoming a
problem for the particular country for
instance well there are on the one hand
reluctance is concerning certain
countries and on the other hand well
general sort of misgivings about the way
the court of justice has gone about that
let me baby start by explaining what the
Court of Justice has done okay there are
certain situations in which it is
probably necessary to accept the
application of such fundamental rights
to the States that is the case when one
can really say that the states are
acting as agents of the Union so the
European Union institutions are going to
adopt some general rules and in order
for all that to work in the Member
States the Member States need to fill
that in and when that is the case when
they are really implementing union law
well one can easily justify that they
also have to comply with the fundamental
rights of the Union where it gets more
problematic is where the Court of
Justice has extended that case law and
started to say that the same fundamental
rights applied to the member states also
when they are just acting within the
scope of Union law and you see of course
that that is much broader and sort of
vague notion to give you maybe one
example sometime back in around 2000 the
Court of Justice had to decide the case
about a woman from the Philippines who
was married to a national of the UK and
that UK national was occasionally
providing services in other member
states he was traveling to France to
sell advertisement space in some
scientific journals and during that time
apparently his wife was taking care of
the children now the problem was that
her residence in the UK was not legal
she had entered illegally and they had
married and she was actually threatened
with expulsion now the question was did
she have a right to the protection of
her family life as a matter of European
Union law and for European Union not to
intervene there at all
one had to see well how far the scope of
Union law actually went and what the
court said following the rather skillful
lawyers of that couple was that in fact
if the lady was expelled from the UK her
husband would no longer be able to
provide services so easily because there
would be someone who would need to look
after the children right therefore
expelling her would restrict his freedom
to provide services therefore we were
aware within the scope scope of European
Union law the freedom to provide
services being guaranteed by the treaty
and therefore she enjoyed protection of
her rights to family life as a matter of
union law that was actually quite a far
reaching decisions and some member
states may not have been entirely
comfortable with that because it now
said
precedent for this happening with other
people who might be in the same
situation it it does certainly it
certainly does and now of course when
you have this prominent list of
fundamental rights this real sort of
Bill of Rights of the Union it draws
much more attention and member states
are well actually Nationals of member
states and third country nationals even
much more likely to rely on it and we're
going to see that we have already seen
actually that the court of justice has
started to police the boundary line
between the scope of application of
European Union law and what is still
left to the Member States more carefully
in cases like the one that I have just
described okay now why are you
particularly interested in the
application of the EU fundamental rights
to the member states wouldn't you expect
them to be there in the first place well
in the first place they are actually
there as I have explained AHA to police
what the union institutions are doing
but there are these specific situations
like the ones that we have just talked
about where it's actually necessary to
apply those fundamental rights to member
states also and this is very interesting
because it creates I mean it leads us to
basic questions relating to the federal
distribution of powers which is an issue
that you have also seen in the United
States I mean the US Bill of Rights in
the American Constitution was initially
drawn up to limit the action of the
federal government and was only with the
14 mm 14th amendment in its
interpretation by the Supreme Court in
the 20th century that one found out that
actually the action of state and local
government was also limited now that may
at the time have been something close to
a revolution and we are certainly not
quite there yet in European Union right
okay
so what are the reasons in in European
Union law to apply the Union fundamental
rights to the Member States well first
of all there is this easier situation
where the member states have to do
something as agents for the European
Union and then there
is this broad category of cases where
nevertheless we are somehow in the scope
of European Union law and today we
actually have a provision which
concretely addresses this it's article
51 of the Charter of Fundamental Rights
which says that member states are only
bound by the fundamental rights of the
Union when they are implementing
European Union law so you might think
that this was actually drafted to limit
the application of those fundamental
rights to the Member States compared
with what the Court of Justice had
already done in cases like the one with
the lady from the Philippines however
some of the drafters of the Charter of
Fundamental Rights in short that there
was some kind of a footnote some
explanatory note which then made a
reference even to this more expansive
case law of the court of trustees so
today it's not entirely sure whether we
have the more narrow notion of
implementation also the broader notion
of being within the scope of union law
and whenever the court of justice in its
more recent cases refers more broadly to
the scope of European Union law those
that are a bit more skeptical tend to
get a bit nervous mm-hmm okay um and
it's but it is really a problem that the
Lisbon Treaty brought about I would say
it's a problem which the Lisbon Treaty
accentuated because now you really have
a very prominent list of fundamental
rights and it's more likely that
individuals are going to invoke them and
at the same time you've also got this
limitation in this article of the
Charter in 51 which is also more
prominent so those who are a bit more
reluctant to give up sovereignty are
going to rely on that and like that you
create some sort of conflicting
expectations and we have already started
to see the consequences that that may
have and what what are you saying well
the consequences have been shifts in
power I would say a shift in power on
the one hand the potential shift of
course from the Member States to the
Union and some member states are trying
to counter that input
I'm thinking of the UK and of Poland who
have insisted on a protocol being added
to the Lisbon Treaty circumscribing very
narrowly in which situations the Charter
would actually apply to those member
states but then we can also see a shift
of power within the member states and to
understand what that shift might be one
needs to look actually at the way
European Union law in general is
enforced in the Member State
whenever someone relies on the right
coming from European Union law for
instance the right to move to another
member state and work there the right to
provide services all courts in a member
state have to enforce that right even
the first instance court somewhere on
the countryside will need to give effect
to that right and the same goes also of
course for fundamental rights so
fundamental rights of European Union law
where they apply to the states will be
applied by all national courts
throughout the Union so the judicial
review will be completely decentralized
by contrast when you enforce national
fundamental rights you very often have
specialization you will have national
constitutional courts that are
specifically going to look at those
fundamental rights issues and they are
going to be the only courts who do that
now when you are in the position of one
of these national courts you are
actually going to be very interested in
finding situations in which can you can
apply Union fundamental rights because
you're allowed to do it yourself you
don't have to go and ask some
constitutional court so these tendencies
of broad decentralized to different
review for matters of European Union law
and concentrated specialised judicial
review for national fundamental rights
create some tensions within the national
systems of judicial protection I could
imagine that it'd be somewhat it could
have the potential of being
I don't want to say confusing but not
necessarily fair across all of the
parties involved perhaps I mean is that
what you're finding that there's there's
quite a bit of difference between how
things are handled well that is one of
the criticisms that are being made
against too expensive case law on the
protection of fundamental rights some
who criticize that case no actually say
that we are creating multiple forums for
discussion discussing debating questions
of fundamental rights you don't need you
don't know anymore whether you need to
go to your local court or whether you
really have to go to the Constitutional
Court and what exactly is going to be
the dividing line that is one of the
criticisms that one can hear indeed okay
so do you think all of this is will will
lead to a power grab by the part of the
Union
I wouldn't necessarily think so first of
all and maybe I should go a little bit
into the cases that the European Court
of Justice has decided during this first
time there has been a first series of
cases in which the court has been very
cautious when it came precisely to the
rights of Nationals of the European
Union European Union citizens who were
married or had some family members who
were third country nationals so a little
bit the situation like the lady from the
Philippines that we're talking about in
the beginning and they're curiously the
court of justice has come to say that
those third country nationals who want
to remain with the Union citizen in the
state of origin of nationality of that
Union citizen are not necessarily within
the scope of European Union law so under
the Lisbon Treaty they can not invoke
the right to family life in order to
obtain the right to live and work in the
member state of origin of their Union
family member
which maybe a bit of reversal of the
earlier case law that I've described so
that was pretty cautious I would say on
the other hand there is one case in
which the court of justice has been
quite expansive and that case is I think
worth going into for a second it is the
case of a Swedish fisherman who
apparently cheated on his tax return
income tax on the one hand and
value-added tax which is some kind of a
sales tax on the other so of course the
Swedish authorities went after him and
inflicted first an administrative
sanction on him and then started also
criminal proceedings and during those
criminal proceedings the national court
in charge of that in Sweden was
wondering whether as a matter of
European Union law the person in
question didn't enjoy the right not to
be tried or prosecuted and sentenced
twice a right which is known in the US
as the prohibition of double jeopardy
right so in order for the court to
address that it first had to say that
that situation was actually within the
scope of European Union law and now one
must know that income tax legislation is
still completely a matter of national
law so that for that part he was
certainly not within the scope of union
law by contrast that you added tax this
sales tax is actually in substance
harmonized at European Union level but
when it comes to sanctions all that the
rule says that the member states have to
ensure that the tax is effectively
collected and they have to prevent
evasion so the question was is that
enough to say that a system of sanctions
administrative and criminal sanctions
for avoidance evasion of value-added tax
came within the scope of European Union
law and the court thought it did
I don't want to go into the details of
the reasoning which some commentators
have criticized as actually not being
entirely convincing but they would like
to underline the importance of the
consequences what this means is that
whenever nowadays a claim and the
European Union law is enforced with the
system of procedural law and sometimes
criminal law in a Member State those
procedural and criminal rules might come
within the scope of European Union law
and might therefore be checked against
the Union fundamental rights and
something that that actually goes very
far in particular the Federal
Constitutional Court in Germany has
actually sent a very clear signal to the
Court of Justice in a ruling in which it
said that it thought that what the court
had done there needed to be understood
very narrowly and limited to the
circumstances of the specific case it
seems very complicated to me that the
way that things are set up where you
have basically the different member
states have their own legal system which
then also plays into the European Union
legal system am i understanding that
correctly absolutely yes and that I mean
that does create a lot of questions I
mean let me let me just look at some of
them one question is of course the
question of democracy right normally you
would expect that you should apply the
set of fundamental rights basic rights
the right not to be tried twice etc
which comes from the polity that has
actually adopted the bulk of the rules
that you're going to apply right it
should be the same that that would be as
a tendency more democratic now the court
has tried to get around that by saying
you can actually apply both yeah as long
as you don't impair the effectiveness of
European Union law you can apply both a
national fundamental right and a union
fundamental right complicated as you
suggest
but one can maybe envisage that in
situations in which we're only talking
about a fundamental right coming from
national law and a similar right which
comes from union law because what you
could do then would be to say well let
the person benefit from the better
protection yeah but as soon as you've
got a situation in which several
fundamental rights of various parties in
the dispute compete it becomes extremely
difficult to see what better protection
is going to mean let's imagine a
situation in which one person wants to
publish something and relies on his or
her freedom of speech and the other
person thinks that this is actually
something very private which should be
protected and relies on the right to
privacy right so then in that case what
is better protection going to be the
better protection of the freedom of
speech is going to be the worst
protection of the right to privacy of
course and in that situation
simply giving preference to European
Union law in a situation which is
otherwise not that closely connected to
European Union law may not be the ideal
solution solution so the question really
is what kind of federal system of
protection of fundamental rights do we
want to create in particular one might
think that there is some value in having
diversity at the beginning when you've
got a certain approach towards let's say
gay marriage in one state and another
approach in another state they can sort
of experiment and the debate that is
being held in the various Member States
may then inform and sharpen the debate
at the central level which is something
that we have seen in the US for instance
well so the question is whether in a
situation like that in which society is
in the process of evolution it is really
a good idea that the court of justice
attracts all that towards it and rules
on it immediately before giving a chance
to these individual different attitudes
and approaches to develop bearing in
mind also that the European Court of
Justice
is not a specialized human-rights cord
it also does many other things okay
so let's take a look at the issues that
you think are rise from the courts
approach that you've just described yes
well there are there are the ones that
I've just mentioned here and I would
maybe like to add also that sort of a
different approach which would speak in
favor of protecting fundamental union
fundamental rights in the Member States
also more broadly might be the situation
in which for one reason or another
fundamental rights protection in the
member a member state fails it just
stops protecting certain fundamental
rights properly in a situation like that
which one may hope will remain entirely
theoretical of course in the European
Union you might want to use Union
fundamental rights at least as a
fallback and that is something which may
have been on the courts mind also when
it decided to draw the scope of Union
fundamental rights more broadly but in
the immediate future what I think the
court will need to do is to clarify its
case law more the tendency is the one
concerning Union citizens on the one
hand and the one concerning this Swedish
taxpayer on the other seem difficult to
reconcile so the court is probably going
to get more questions from national
court national courts and it will have
to refine its case law and to engage in
this judicial and maybe sometimes also
extra judicial dialogue with national
courts in order to convince them so I
think this is certainly going to be a
space to be watched in the near future
right it sounds like it will be a
process that evolves over time
absolutely
well thank you very much for being here
with us today and sharing some of your
work thank you subpoena pick up for more
information about mr. Shima and his
research please visit our website at
yale.edu slash McMillan report be sure
to join us again for another episode of
the McMillan
port made possible through funding from
the Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center
for International and area studies at
Yale